it's been a it's been a transformational
experience I don't know what to say I
feel like I'm introducing a UFC fighter
I like where you get at 500b 300b we'll
let that information out insh tal
without any further Ado please help us
welcome brother Muhammad hijab a person
who needs no
[Applause]
introduction alum
sometimes I
wonder sometimes I wonder when I look at
the circus of
animals that how such a big elephant can
be
subdued sometimes I look at these
animals not just elephants but Lions
Maybe
and other wild animals in the circus in
zoos and how could they be
subdued you see I've done a little bit
of research and I
found that what they do with the
elephant is that they take the elephant
when it's a small elephant and they tie
it up they punish the elephant they tie
the elephant up to a
pole and the Elephant can't move out of
its place
and so the elephant thinks because of
that that it's incapable even when the
elephant grows and becomes many tons
very heavy and big
animal whenever the elephant sees the
pole and sees the
circus trainer or whatever they call
them they are frightened and they cannot
move out of that place they have to just
see the chains and the pole and they'll
be
subdued Arnold toin he referred to the
Muslim umah as a sleeping
giant and the reason why is because we
have a rich and proper civilizational
history the thing is the Muslim world
today by population is about 1.8 billion
people we have capabilities the like of
which we don't recognize
ourself we are like the
elephant that has
grown and we see the
chains and for some reason we think we
can't break free from those
chains for some reason even though we do
have the
capabilities even though we can move out
of place even though there's no way the
Zookeeper or the circus keeper can keep
us in that station rep position
we still feel the inferiority
complex the postc colonial
trauma we still feel as if the Zookeeper
can keep us in that place but the truth
is and we all know this to be the case
we all know this to be the
truth is that we're capable of Breaking
Free from the chains
the Muslim
people are one of if not the biggest and
strongest force in the world
[Music]
today and do you know who knows that
more than we
do the Americans know that just read
their
reports American academics know that
look at Samuel P Huntington very famous
book Clash of civilization ations where
he says that Civilization will Clash on
cultural lines and that the big enemy
will be he States the Islamic
civilization there are seven
civilizations in the world he says the
big enemy is the Islamic civilization
there's going to be a massive Clash so
what's the hidden message that
Huntington and Bernard Lewis and all of
these orientalists of the Modern Age
want to portray want to give to their
policy makers the message is keep the
foot on this giant that's the
message and you know what I'll be honest
with you guys we were for too
long in a
somnambulant state we were the Sleeping
Giant and we didn't even know that we
were
sleeping but when the
Israelis or to be more spefic Pacific
the Israeli
defense or
so-called defense we should just call
them the apartheid state for now when
the apartheid
state the religiously or the ethnically
supremacist state of Israel decided to
kill children for no reason drop bombs
instead of facing their supposed enemy
face to
face they are destroying hospitals
they are killing young ones
children babies and they're justifying
everything with post Hawk
rationalization everything is being
justified not only that but proponents
here in the west are justifying it as
well in the on the right wing and in the
center even some elements of the left
wing and other elements are not even
saying a word haven't you know noticed
that have you noticed
that have you noticed that the media
machine the propaganda
machine is more vehement than
ever have you
noticed that the people have now come
together and showed Collective apathy
for the Palestinian
people the problem is
in so
doing in not caring for
us they have incentivized us to care for
ourselves in hating us they've
incentivized us to love each
other in fact what I've also
noticed is that by justifying what
they're
justifying they are essentially waking
up the sleeping giant of
Islam we needed something big to be
woken from that
Slumber we needed something big we
needed a proper slap to the face and
here we have
it The Masks have dropped here you have
it the same
people proponents from the and the right
and the politicians and
others in the
west and the EU Canada
Australia us
Alliance none of them no politician has
come out and said
categorically we condemn what's going on
in terms of killing of civilians
incredible
shocking isn't that
shocking in one way is shocking but in
another way it's not
surprising because the West has never
been morally consistent as M said the
West has only been strategically
consistent why do we expect them to be
moral but now we will use this as an
ample example when they come and said
well your Prophet killed this and you
believed in that and you done this and
your religion is a religion of that say
shut your
mouth shut your
mouth you have no moral High get off
your moral High
Ground there is no moral High
Ground stop pretending that you're
compassionate stop pretending that you
care about the death of Civilian people
stop pretending that you're going to
civilize
us stop pretending that you're an
anti-terrorism you're anti- unstr
terrorism that's what you
are stop pretending you don't like
domination you love it you love
domination everywhere whether it's
geopolitics or in your own bedrooms
where you do
BDSM and that is statistically
proven yes it is statistically proven I
can give you the
sources
primary sources secondary sources I mean
those are primary
sour they pretend as if they are going
to civilize
us they're not going to civilize
us they're not fit to civilize us they
speak to us as if they're our judge
they're not our judge they're not fit to
be our judge
and in fact the Quran tells us
this that they don't care to uphold ties
of kinship with you or contracts with
you treaties with you you don't care
about
that him they want to just say kind
words with their
mouths and their hearts dislike you
they're repellent of
you and most of them are
evildoers this is the reality of the
state of the enemies of Islam and the
Muslims they
pretend they pretend to care they
pretend
but they don't
care so now that we have
diagnosed the
issue the all important
question is what do we do next and of
course we have to start and it's not
tokenistic and it's not cliche and it's
not a tick Bo box exercise we have to
start by saying we the Muslim people
believe that the greatest weapon of all
is the supplication to Allah is the Dua
to Allah that Allah alleviates the
suffering of the people of Palestine say
a
mean may Allah alleviate the suffering
of the people of
Palestine may Allah alleviate the
suffering of the people of Palestine may
Allah give them Victory a may Allah give
them Victory a is that how much you want
it may Allah give them
Victory and we mean that collectively
and individually
we say this because
W that is the key but having said
that Allah tells us to
prepare prepare for them what you can
from
strength so how do we prepare here in
the
west what's our response here in the
west have you
noticed I have never seen this
in the last decade two decades three
decades where I've been following this
conflict very closely I've never
seen I have not
seen that they are now associating the
Palestinian flag itself with terrorism
have you noticed
this is this the case here in Canada as
well it's unbelievable they're all
singing from the same Hy she isn't it
the UK the US and Canada the Bastion of
freedom of expression
the Bastion of freedom of speech they're
telling us you know that flag which
evidently they didn't know that the
white man actually made that flag
anyway when they were partitioning and
breaking up our
countries but actually the white man did
it but for that that that flag now we we
consider it to be a terrorist
symbol if you go to
protest now you're supporting a a
proscribed terrorist organization
and you might have and I'll ask you guys
because I want to know from you just as
much as maybe you want to know some
things from me which
is have you felt who of you have been
vocal about the Palestinian issue put
your hands
up okay many of you actually the
majority of you who have you have
received some level of backlash from any
organization see that's a that's a chunk
that's almost half of the people who put
up their hands can you see because it's
not just a legal thing here it's not
just the the state and the police but
it's also the institutions they're
trying to shut you
up they're trying to gag
you so what's the answer to that
question obviously we want to be as
smart as possible and where the risk
doesn't need to be taken don't take it
however having said
this they're looking for our
insecurities let me tell you what
they're doing they come together maybe
Trudeau and
sunak and Biden I don't know maybe they
and his you know Cara or whatever he's
got responsible adult I don't know what
because of his
condition and he's sitting there and
they all may be sitting down drinking
something maybe eating some pancakes
some Canadian pancakes or some syrup
and they said what are we going to do
said get Netanyahu on the phone said get
him on the phone okay
Netanyahu hello Netanyahu
BB and then he because he's got such a
grip on them he says this he's faci he
says it's not B it's
Habibi that we're capable so anyway what
should we do say
look you're going to have to crash
because now PR is a big thing they all
know it's a big thing look Israel has a
tourist industry they're trying to
attract multinational
corporations they're trying to be a
developed
economy say look the biggest thing you
have to mitigate from your side this is
the conversation the biggest thing you
have to mitigate from your side is you
have to mitigate public
reactions so anyone who's
involved in protesting or anything like
that at every level there must be some
some kind of
suppression okay so we're going to
introduce anti-terror laws we're going
to do this and we're going to do that
and we're going to threaten them and
we're going to scare them why because
they don't want to be called terrorists
Muslims don't want to be called
terrorists Muslims are scared to be
called terrorists
Muslims are worried that the white man
might tell them that they're a terrorist
because they can't live a civil society
can't live a proper life if that's the
case so if they want to go down that
direction you endanger their life you
endanger their careers you endanger
everything label them stigmatize them
say that they're terrorists you're
sympath you're a terrorist
sympathizer like that little weasel Ben
Shapiro he said anyone who calls for a
ceasefire is a terrorist
sympathizer he's something else which
begins with the first three
letters
but that man there who couldn't show up
to the fight and who by the way I don't
know if you know this but everywhere he
goes he's got so many security guards
when I saw your own Jordan
Peterson who now has shown his true
colors he came in he sent a military man
into the mosque to see what's going on
before he could come in The Wimp And in
the last minute he had a last minute
replacement he said look it's not just
going to be me it's going to be me and
my friend as you say wait a minute this
is to all r no problem come on let's do
it and even then he was forced to the
worst admissions he said I don't want to
maybe I don't want to be a rational
actor said the Trinity is not the
Trinity doesn't make sense I said he
said maybe I don't want to be a rational
actor so maybe a feminist can say the
same thing to you then say it's this and
that maybe I don't want to be a rational
actor I can be whatever I want a
transgender can say the same thing to
you so he's a rationalist everywhere
except with Islam that shows you the
power of Islam anyway that fool there
who's getting $50 million a year
probably by daily wire and other people
that they pay that's a lot of
money I don't know about you guys I
think that's a lot of money
me I mean there are economies in the
world actually I don't think there are
but anyway I was going to say whose GDP
is that but it's it's not it's there
isn't but anyway the point is
this is that those individuals there
they're coming together in unity and
they want to label us it's terrorist
sympathize this that whatever here's my
response okay here's my response and
take this from me I am a master
manipulator just ask my
wife okay who's also now unfortunately
the same
thing and so it's become like uh the
cold war in the
house because I told her some of my
tricks but just take it from me if what
they're doing is they're looking for
your insecurities as the brown man the
Muslim the other then what are we going
to do we're going to look for their
insecurities and I can tell you from
being in the west and living and you
agree with me the number one thing I
would say up there maybe number two or
three to Peter filia or something but
one of the worst things a white person
does not want to be smeared with is what
racism thank you very much oh ho oh
ho aha he's already they're listening to
me and when I said racism something
happened one of them started
stuttering the other one started
producing diarrhea in the
stomach and the other one actually
soiled
himself the point I'm making to you is
racism now how can you accuse you know
they're calling us Terror sympathizer
for calling for a Seas fire or for
supporting Israel uh supporting
Palestine okay so let's let me let me
play Ro role reversal now what is uh uh
what is Israel according to
international law according to
international law in 1973 there was
something called the aparte
convention there was something called
what the aparte convention all right one
of the things which it said is that if
there are laws which discriminate based
on race then that country fulfills the
conditions of being an AP parid State
now in Israel there are many laws which
fulfill the
condition of discrimination based on
race one of them I'll just give you one
example there's many but this is just
one it's something called the right of
return law that you have a right to come
back to Israel if you're an ethnic Jew
if you convert to Islam or Christianity
by the way that right is stripped by the
way now this is something there's no
there's no discussion about it you can't
say well like what they're doing with
the hospital maybe it's a Hamas uh a
missile maybe this maybe that you're
scrambling you're squabbling you're
stuttering you're moving you're do
you're trying to justify postto anything
you're trying to Gaslight us you're
trying to tell us we're not seeing what
we're seeing fine for the argument I'm
telling you there's a law here in this
country which you are supporting which
says that you can discriminate on the
basis of
race so what is it then what do you
become if you become a supporter of that
country
aha what you become if you don't allow
criticism of such a country you can
argue you're you're a racist
sympathizer or maybe you're a racist
because we are planning talking
condemning
discussing the anti-apartheid
regime the apartheid regime we are
trying to criticize the apartheid regime
you're getting on the way of that you
are the
equivalent of the person who got on the
way of Nelson
Mandela it's the it's actually worse
I've been to South Africa they're yes
there are no but W it's worse it is
worse because in South Africa there
wasn't provinces where this kind of
thing was falling uh there weren't
dropping missiles on them like that they
wasn't doing that yes there was bad
things happening but it wasn't to this
level it's worse than South Africa
was but at the time do you think people
thought that South Africa was bad Tony
Blair who was the then prime minister of
the United Kingdom right before the apar
not before the apart in fact because
they finished 94 but the English don't
know who it was at the time the
British had alliances with South Africa
many Western countries had alliances
with South Africa because it fulfilled
their policies remember we said the West
is strategically consistent and not
morally consistent the point is
this now we're going to fight fire with
fire so if they say to you such and such
say I have reason to
believe I have reason to believe that
you are
racist I have reason to believe and
obviously consult the defamation
lawyers and I will announce
something that since
now every tweet I put out brings 20,000
likes in 10 minutes or some Madness like
that I will help you how we've put in
place a designated service
where you can send the following I'm
going to Tweet it after this lecture
you're going to put the person who's
harassing you you're going to if you can
get a picture of
[Applause]
them because you know why they're doing
it to you do you know why they're doing
it to you because they think that that's
going to D your think thinking they know
what you're thinking I want to get a job
I want to live a normal life I don't
want to do something that's going to
impact that but do you know what we're
going to do we're going to make them
think the same
thing what what the white man wants a
job he wants to have a life he wants
this a night it's not just a white man
I'm talking about the liberal this that
the right-wing the cist whoever it is
who's not sympathetic with us
effectively that's who I'm talking about
that person okay if you're not
sympathetic with us you're going to try
and gag us you're going to try and
suppress us you're going to try and
harass us we're going to name and we're
going to shame and we're going to label
and we're going to stigmatize and that's
our protest that's our resistance how
about
that so you got to fight fire with
fire and let me tell you something for a
long time the Institute that I work with
we formulate Arguments for a living
that's what we do we formulate Arguments
for the veracity of Islam for this for
that we do that for a living and I've
noticed one
thing after all of that time in The
Institute formulating all these
arguments the arguments are not the most
powerful way to convince
people that attitude is more important
than
arguments if they see in
you if they see in you if they sniff
from you fear hesitation
worry they will take advantage of
you we were just talking
today here in Canada you have
Bears what what's this keep talking
about animals Bears Lions you do have
Bears when I first came to Canada in
2019 I went to up to a place where there
was Bears I don't know I can't even
remember the place where it's called and
the guy told me look there's three kinds
of bears
I said why are you telling me this
information I said he said listen he
said just hold on for a second my friend
yeah I said what are he goes grizzly
bear there's the blue bear whatever okay
I said he goes we're going into the
forest now and he said that if you see a
grizzly bear you're
finished you've got no
chance I said are you sure about that my
friend he said yes he said yes he said
but there's this kind of bear I think
it's a blue bear you guys can correct me
if I'm wrong
oh you all know
it is that there's one and I thought the
guy was joking I actually thought the
guy was joking he said look if you see a
black bear and it tries to attack you
give it all you've
got he said Shout Scream punch don't
show him fear I don't have you ever been
given this advice by the
way
huh back oh don't say that brother
that's
racist
anyway so if it's a black bear I know
what you're saying brother of course
you're talking about the bear not the
not the
people it sounds like something you know
one of the white apartheid guys from
South Africa would say if it's black
fight
back if if it's ground lay down is that
what it say there's three there's three
of them if it's black fight back if it's
brown lay down and if it's white good
night well I tell you what whatever the
situation right most of us are black and
brown the point is this is
that you've got to deal with them the
enemies of Islam I I say them by the way
I'm talking about the the people
harassing us I'm not talking about all
the non-muslims just to be clear of
course we're not talking about those
we're talking about the enemies of Islam
and Muslims the people who are harassing
us about Palestinian activism let me be
clear about that are we clear about
that yes we're clear about that if we
see those people trying to harass us
deal with them like you would deal with
a brown
bear sorry sorry don't do that with a
black bear no honestly because the black
bear if you sees you're on it you know
seriously if he sees you're on it he he
will respect you for the most part
that's how it is I still live in a place
in London where it's rough and I had a
surgery the other day I was feeling a
bit vulnerable and I saw some some guys
and I started doing
this no word of a lie I went to South
Africa I went to a certain area in
Durban they said
listen this area they're going they're
going to do something to you so I just
walked around like
that so the amount of threat is
commensurate with the amount or the
amount of intimidation is is commens
with the amount of threat the point is
if they are giving you that you have to
give it to them back attitude eats
Arguments for breakfast it's all about
the attitude you
have we are in a very special time in
history in the 1960s in the west we had
the Civil Rights Movement
we did and there were different
approaches to how to deal with the
situation the most successful approach
was rebellion was resistance no doubt
about it and if it wasn't like that if
it wasn't resistance and I'm not talking
about physical violence or I know the
the FBI here the Canadian alternative
what are they
called r r r c m e m B
BB whoever they are man I know they're
here so listening to
me whatever they are they're the most
kind officers in the world I me Canadian
people are very nice
anyway I'm pretty sure if they saw me
doing something criminal say hey what
are you doing there you
know very kind people from one
perspective but from another perspective
trying to harass
us that's the truth so what I'm saying
is if you sense that you've got because
this the thing it's not about the
Palestine conflict although that's very
important it's about you and me building
character it's about what we're what
we're ready to accept and agree
to said great
Arabic
poet he
said he said the one who
is
always being
defeated humiliated it becomes easier to
be humiliated again just like and he
says the following a corpse a dead
person you know a dead
person when you try obviously when you
translate poetry look how horrible it is
I mean but if you get a dead person and
you're stabbing up a dead person so the
dead person can't feel anything the
point is is if humiliation
becomes common place to you you will be
numbed to
humiliation humiliation will be easy for
you they'll tell you don't do it today
don't do this don't do that don't do
that even though it's legal fully
illegal and you will you'll be scared
and you'll be this and that and if
that's your personality then you're just
like a dead man walking you're better
under the ground than you are over the
ground what kind of life is that anyway
because every child Every Woman every
man that's
dying in in that area although their
bodies are dead their spirit is the most
alive of
all that they are being provided for by
Allah subhana wa tala they have more
dignity than we can ever dream of
having but in in commemoration in
respect to that dignity we can't if a
woman a child a man is going out and
putting themselves In Harm's Way
protesting in the West Bank in Gaza in
all these places being killed being
sniped being bombed being
harmed if they are putting themselves in
that situation and they don't mind to do
so and in fact it actually makes them
even more Brazen flagrant
then how could it be that we in the west
will be scared will be whipped into
submission will be subdued will be
subjugated will be subjugated by the
dominant
population I don't want to pontificate
in a cesped alian way what I will say
here is that we have a moral duty
there's no doubt about it we have a
moral duty and we are living in history
and our great grandchildren will ask us
they will ask us what did you do in 200
23 what did you do when you had the
capability to go online to make as much
noise through this thing called the
internet where for all of
humankind for the majority of the
conflict of Israel and Palestine such a
thing didn't exist we can make a change
we will make a change
because we are the sleeping
giant we are the Sleeping Giant and
we're starting to wake
up but for us to wake up in an efficient
and proper
manner we have to have no
fear we have to not care too much about
the
consequences just do
it whether it's activism whether it's
protesting whether it's going online
whether it's blogging whether it's
making an an article making a website
the public relations angle is the
strongest thing that we can hold on to
and by the way that's an ocean that's
not aess poool public relations in the
internet is an
ocean what we can do collectively in the
west with the English
language affecting discourse directly
did you not see when I went on Pier's
Mor Morgan show and all the comments and
millions of people and another person
came on afterwards
whose name was Basim YF and together it
accumulated a whopping 22 to 25 million
views which is about almost the
population of the entire country of
Canada 39 million or something right 40
million tell me if that's not going to
change The Narrative of course it's
going to change the
narrative the media representatives are
already on the back foot they're
changing their
tone and we can do it
and we will do it and there have been
examples in the past where the pressure
has mounted on these people and it has
led
them to cease fires the pr thing is a
big thing for
them they have a country they want to
run I'm telling you put the pressure on
them with
that I will
conclude
more